hi i'm austin butler and uh i'm here
with buzzfeed to answer questions with
puppies i'm so excited
bring in the puppies oh my god
hello hello
hi
what's your name
hello
oh my god
oh my god the puppy breath
it kills me
amazing when you have like watched
footage for so long and then you finally
get to see
all the work that goes into into
costumes and stuff oh you're so sweet
[Music]
it was five months of baz and i
exploring and you know experimenting
with things we had so much fun together
but it was a long process
it's such a terrifying thing because
elvis has the most iconic voice i
listened to him
every day and
i worked with some of the best singing
coaches that i could find and we just
had so much fun getting to
explore that
death time it is so hard to answer
questions when you're surrounded by
puppies right now i'm just focusing on
on one thing at a time i'm just just
acting right now but i love music and i
had so much fun
[Music]
oh my gosh this little guy you want to
play me
my buddy callum turner i mean we don't
necessarily look identical but i i think
he knows me very well so yeah that would
be nice
you know the surreal thing is when you
see like in this film the manson
part of the world and it's it's weird
that i i
lived in that in a whole different realm
what are you doing it would be weird to
see them all in the same room
oh tom is just the greatest i've known
who he was my entire life so
um yeah that watch tastes good it was
amazing to get to work with him he's
just the nicest guy and i was really
nervous before because it's that thing
of meeting your heroes and he just
turned out to be the most open-hearted
generous guy and we had so much fun
together
i
romeo and juliet i saw that when i was
uh very young
and i didn't know movies could be made
like that so that that film really
impacted me
it was an incredibly immersive
experience australia's is such a
wonderful place and so i i just got to
go to the beach every day during the six
months that the film was shut down so i
could just completely immerse myself and
um it really allowed for that um and the
people out there are so great so kind
and yeah we had a great time
i don't know i auditioned for so many
roles in my life that i didn't get um
and uh that's that's the whole i
remember when i started people would say
you have to audition for 100 things
before you book one that was a lot of
the beginning of my career like
auditioning for the hunger games or any
one of those things
[Music]
oh
[Music]
are you succession i love that show so
much
ashley tisdale shoot definitely that's
your answer
right on the lips
[Music]
i i just i i feel so grateful that
people have watched anything that i've
done so the fact that people
even use the word fan i just feel so
flattered by it thank you for everybody
who's
ever wanted to watch something that i've
done
i don't know i it's it's weird that
there's so many little like lily pads
that you sort of jump on that get you
from one moment in your career the next
i think a big one for me was when i did
um i did this play in new york that one
with denzel called the iceman coming
that was a
a goal of mine for a long time to do a
play in new york and um so that was very
that was a special moment
oh man so all of them like leo and brad
and quentin were all beyond heroes for
for my whole life so
suddenly being on set with them i i it
it felt like a dream it was it was
so surreal
and then they were all just
they went far
um
beyond anything i could have imagined as
far as like their generosity and
kindness and
um and work ethic and everything was
just it was so cool
i think a raging bull i'd want to watch
that again for the first time as i've
never seen it
[Music]
yes sean cassidy and david cassidy both
they gave me a lot of advice around it
because
shawn especially told me a lot about
just longevity and
like mentorship and that sort of thing
so that was well don't bite the ball
even putting my name in the category of
that feels so strange to me um i i grew
up right next to disneyland so going to
disneyland that was the thing that i did
with my mom a lot uh when i was a kid so
the idea of just going there and walking
around for hours sounds really fun
yeah i usually take a prop home uh
i
i took many things from elvis but one is
the leather jumpsuit uh it's not even
called the jumpsuit but the leather 68
special uh
that he wore and i took that home
maybe american trilogy
uh but but i wouldn't want to live a
life without all of us songs um but yeah
american trilogy because it because
there's it's basically three songs in
one thank you buzzfeed thanks for
letting me play with these puppies today
be sure and go see elvis in theaters
very soon all of these puppies are
adoptable at the humane society of
memphis and shelby county
[Music]
you